a few regions of New York state could
reopen Friday amid a drastic decline in
new cases and deaths it's the type of
gradual approach being met with protests
elsewhere
the employee parking lot at Tesla's car
Factory in California was packed Friday
after CEO Elon Musk told staff to get
back to work in defiance of local
guidelines or lead national
correspondent David Beck know is in New
York City David how long before all of
New York is open again
well good morning from Times Square
where it is empty look the governor says
it would take a miracle for New York
City to reopen before June but as you
noted in three regions in upstate New
York Anthony where the governor jokes
there are more cows than people some
businesses will be able to resume
limited operations starting this Friday
from my point of view were on the other
side of the mountain
the governor of New York Andrew Cuomo
announced the beginning of what he calls
a new chapter in the fight against the
corona virus as cases and
hospitalizations continue their weeks
long decline but it's an exciting new
phase we're all anxious to get back to
work
in Florida Governor Ron de Santos
allowed some barber shops and salons to
reopen Monday making sure that everyone
sanitizes and washing their hands before
they come in or when they come in and as
appointment it's come to the shop
they'll have to wait in their car you
know Florida is one of several states
where an updated model from the
University of Washington projects that
kovat related deaths through August will
rise faster than expected
due largely because stay at home orders
are being relaxed the models have not
been accurate the recent governor De
Santis is brushing aside those numbers
is because earlier projections he says
overestimated the virus's impact on
Florida we need to go based off facts
and based off evidence and not go based
off conjecture in Fremont California
cars packed the parking lot of this
Tesla facility a notable increase from
last week as the company reopened its
factory in defiance of local health
orders on Twitter Tesla's founder and
CEO Elon Musk wrote I will be on the
line with everyone else if anyone is
arrested I ask that it only be me south
of Denver in Castle Rock Colorado on
Monday crowds ignoring social distancing
orders returned for a second day to C&C
breakfast even after local officials
issued an order to close for 30 days
after the restaurant packed in crowded
customers many of whom were not wearing
a mask people need to stand up for the
freedom and the restaurants owner Jesse
R Elano says he's prepared to face the
consequences for his actions if we have
disobedience you're gonna say well we're
gonna lock down more now it's not about
health anymore now they're telling you
we got the power you will comply or
we're gonna punish you
so social distancing continues to be a
problem intentional or not take for
example this photo this was tweeted by a
doctor who had come to New York to
actually volunteer to treat Kovac
patients while he was headed home to the
west coast and he says United Airlines
emailed him saying hey listen we think
the flight might be full but we're gonna
keep the middle seats empty well they
were not he tweeted the photo it went
viral and now United says here's what
we're gonna try and do we are going to
attempt to call people in advance if it
looks like the flight is going to be
full and once you get to the gate if the
flight is 70% full we will allow you to
change your ticket Tony
all right we hope everyone's okay social
distancing or not David thank you very
much